like you're probably not going to be
able to walk around web 3 that easily
and web 3 is already here what the [ __ ]
does web 3 even mean it's a [ __ ]
term
it's a [ __ ] term like when people
ask me hey man what are the best web 3
coins i'm like [ __ ] this is web3
like we're in web 3. okay so we're in
web so it's like version 3 of the web
well yeah so like we're removing sort of
the
the big tech giants from the equation or
at least that's what we're trying to do
not only the financial middlemen but the
social middlemen
we want to essentially eliminate a lot
of these
corporations with so much power over us
through web3 and that that suck the
profits so like your data
your your like facebook and twitter it's
ownership that's probably the best way
to how is that going to happen do you
know how much money i've made from just
using d5 protocols like i don't even
know what a d5 protocol is
from d5 projects so like the ethereum
name service right
you know you know e s domains dot eth
you ever heard those no you've seen
those so it's like so so the
blockchainboy.com the blockchainboy.ethe
exists okay and instead of okay okay.eth
yeah that's why those twitter people
have their twitter name dot eth exactly
so instead of a [ __ ] wallet like no
one wants to use that you just type in
the blockchainboy.eth and you can send
me whatever you want for better for
worse that's just in the browser
uh in any browser in a in a like
metamask or like a if you want to send
me crypto it's an address but you could
also use it as a domain name um you know
okay if you want to really build
decentralized websites um you know icp
is probably my favorite like
decentralized
way to build stuff because they do it
more on the blockchain instead of
compromising on central and easy use
case example would be like pre-search
have you heard of pre-search no
pre-search is like
google that doesn't screw you
like
so every time i search on pre-search
instead of google getting paid by
xyz advertiser right right i get paid
so i hook my wallet up to pre-search
and now every time i search for
something it's a search engine it
actually searches google yahoo
duckduckgo youtube like all these other
sites
and now
when i search for something yeah
i see my account go up by like 15 cents
every time i search like brave browser
you heard a braid browser
i have heard of that yeah basic
attention token
uh you're rewarded for the ads that you
see essentially and stuff like that so
you get paid to use it we're taking
we're taking the we're taking away the
the tools that made the the you know the
elon musks the tech giants of the world
and giving it to the people that use the
networks in the first place
uh i i got an airdrop for having an
ethereum
name
and that airdrop was worth
three to four thousand dollars i wasn't
they did a business insider article
about it air drop that was cool air
drops are [ __ ] sweet dude what the
[ __ ] is an air drop dude if you if
you're if you're an
hey he works earlier
full time
i just [ __ ] do these podcasts but
i've this is like the second or third
crypto podcast i've ever done
we can get really we can get people man
yeah oh bro i'm still on wednesday it
would take weeks and weeks and weeks
think of it like this like like uh
you're being rewarded
for using a network
and providing value to that network
who who pays you
the same people that would pay the
company so well no just routed through
you it is no not necessarily air drops
are a little different so oh not for air
drops i was talking about like with
pre-search and the advertisers yeah
that's that's owning your own data like
like you're you you have you have value
to like every other the term like if the
product's free you're the product
yes yeah so that's like on websites when
you go and use a free product they're
collecting data about you right and
selling it to another company right and
then that person is profiting off of it
and it's like leaving you in the dust
with no
show for anything
that you just provided to that company
see what i mean so web
three
is essentially a way to
not
sort of it's complicated to explain
without being too like detailed about it
but the dns airdrop it was a governance
airdrop so a governance token was
airdropped to you uh depending on how
long you'd had your name how many you
had how long you
basically reserved it for
some people made 60 grand man i mean it
was crazy you know that people really
make a lot of money from these you know
we had one called looks rare
uh it's an nft marketplace
and i think my airdrop from that was
like
five grand maybe six
and and now look like like it's not like
here's just five thousand dollars
congratulations for holding yourself you
gotta qualify for them like well also
like why you would get airdropped like
you said it airdropped a government's
token right so like if i own something
and i'm on that network right
and they know that i'm a holder of
whatever that is
right they can then
program it to go okay we're gonna do a
massive airdrop right hook up your
wallet those parameters will validate
that you are an owner of xyz coin right
and then we're now giving all the owners
of this an airdrop of tokens right in
that case was a governance token
so now they're air dropping these
governance tokens and now when he says
like oh i made five grand off of that he
then took the governance tokens that he
got and was like i'm gonna sell these
right away because they're valuable yeah
right people take the [ __ ] government
and crash
and sell it
right and then boom you got an airdrop
of five thousand dollars worth of
governance tokens that you just sold
immediately so on these uh search
engines or browsers or whatever are
there people like
people paying to be seen on there
i mean it's just like any other
any other browser it just it's rewarding
you for using it i mean i'm not a huge
brave guy i've never really used you
know josh is a big brave browser guy but
you know uh best example of this that
people that is topical that people will
know is this looks rare marketplace that
just dropped because open seas terrible
they blew up real quick they didn't have
the staff to support billions of dollars
flowing in and they made some mistakes
and that's you know it's okay openc
they've done a lot for the space but
there's another entity marketplace
called looks rare that air dropped a
bunch of tokens to anyone who would like
traded nfts on openc i believe and all
you had to do
was like list an nft on their
marketplace
and people got a lot of money from that
and so now they're a real competitor
they're sometimes out doing the volume
on openc
so how do you think that these types of
browsers or search engines or whatever
are going to take over websites like
twitter and facebook
and decentralize
the powers that be on the internet
um the monopolies
it's gonna be niche for a while but i
think we'll see
if we if we continue to see the crypto
market grow and expand i think we'll see
better alternatives form
because people there's a financial
incentive for people to be on these
platforms so
they're rewarded for using these
platforms and you know it's hard to turn
that down especially when you know
you're getting a comparable experience
but it's not going to be easy by any
means and a lot of what like these big
web 2 companies are doing is they're
kind of trying to co-op the movement
back in 2017 it was really core defy
people
i mean look at look at who sits on the
hedera hashgraph the council right and
there is not a very good network in my
opinion
but you can have your opinions they're
doing good steps they're trying to
decentralize at this point of a
blockchain
but the council members on hedera are
huge corporations
is that really the spirit of what that
is is then is that the network we want
to use
i don't think so personally
it's it's a fine line too because you
know like you were saying
like with uh
open c being too too big and or
not being big enough to handle
everything
like with a lot of the stuff dowse that
come up and and these different
protocols that come up
um
like
there's a lot of unforeseen consequences
that can occur
and stuff that we can or they're trying
to hold you know big tech accountable
for like you see the hearings and this
and that they drag like jack dorsey or
you know whoever out in front of the
committees and you know it's like to the
to the mass public it's it's kind of a
uh a wake-up call to realize like oh wow
our politicians don't know [ __ ] about
the internet you know and they're trying
to write hilarious yeah it's it's rough
but then to that same fact it's like
those types of hearings and pressures on
those guys are what stop you know like
like trafficking from going on on
twitter or sites it's those type of
pressures that like stop that so when
you have a decentralized network
you really need to and why we say like
oh community is so important like
you need to foster a good community like
you need to build a good community
otherwise the project could go south
real fast
you know because who knows who comes
onto that network or what the governance
is